et ce soir le 17e festival de radio
france à montpellier accueille gérard
depardieu comme récitant d'une version
très poétique du carnaval des animaux
l'oeuvre de camille saint saëns karine
comazzi et pascal pons était hier à la
générale c'est l'histoire d'un enfant
qui s'endort sur une plage de sable
blond dans son rêve il devient un homme
gérard depardieu sortis des entrailles
d'un énorme manivelle lorsque je sortis
du ventre de la baleine
ge était couvert de vases de mucus est
de blancheton et j'ai poussé un cri
l'homme veut rencontrer les animaux les
mots de marie darrieussecq
il est convenu la bâche le cochon cheval
encore dans 6 des images qui défilent un
mélange de genres qui évoque l'enfance
fantastique
jusqu au pianiste bête de scène
joyeusement malmené toujours un plaisir
aller dans des voies qui sont inconnus
et je trouve que c'est avec les autres
qu'on apprend il trouve que la vision de
ce quartier une disons très poétique
s'est pas complètement inattendu c'est
s'est parlé d' les animaux exact c'est
pas et justement c'est ça que j'aime
c'est que c'est une chose qui me
surprend gym c'est un monde de
l'imaginaire et jeu tout en général les
gens à utiliser leur imagination
moi j'ai voulu que ce soit un poème
merveilleux très féerique des crises
peut suffire il constante quoi qui nous
ramène toujours à l'enfance et cette
enfance où on est tout de même toujours
assez féroce sont exempts très craintif
et puis c'est l'animal qui dans son rêve
le ramène dans un monde plus pur que
celui des hommes de cette fantaisie
zoologique on retient surtout cela la
joie sauvages animales d'artistes
service
deux combats
je le lis finale